e aí galera que assistiu ao canal tudo
bem com vocês hoje é dia dos namorados e
vocês vão ver por aí várias declarações
da boa no instagram no facebook twiter
cef chevette branco e as declarações
elas são muito superficiais assim elas
são tudo o que é possível do
relacionamento existe muito mais coisas
em relação ao então resolvi fazer uma
música romântica muito sincera tivesse
gostado e quero deixar o seu lic e
mostrar para sua cremosinho então lá
descobre sua boca linda quando a cola
parece que você beijou o de uma bota o
ovo 181
parece a minha e quando acordam parece
que eu meu onde um tamanduá-bandeira
tapuya noidz bomdia você comendo até
parece um pedreiro não deixa nenhum
caroto de arroz pra dentro daquela vêem
que você chegou na festa do milho de
maquiagem do olho diria que ganha 0 do
borrado parece os anais
eu pedi a deus não a princesa mas eu não
sou nem um príncipe encantado
as princesas deus me mandou a pior e eu
sou só eu que vai morrer do seu lado e
que adora minha calcinha é você que é um
ombro mas é minha é você parece
princesinha
mas quando vai mal aniversário como
todas as coxinhas
é você que eu quero matrimônio é você
não maior patrimônio é você define é o
demônio e quando fez a regar são o
buraco da camada de ozônio que mostrava
sua memória dessas você amar de verdade
apesar de toda dificuldade
[Música]
eu sempre pedia a deus uma princesa
mas eu entrei eu não sou nem visita
encantar das princesas deus me mandou lá
funciona
eu sou chefe do seu lado
eis que adora minha fã cia elas vêem que
é um ogro mais em mim é você
mas quando vai o aniversário acaba tudo
todas coxinha é você e eu quero
matrimônio é você não maior patrimônio é
você de tpm é o demônio e quando chegar
a roma o buraco na camada de ozono
[Música]
se você gostou identificou esta profunda
não se esquece de que gostei e começa
aqui em baixo os comentários não da sua
cozinha a sua vizinha ansel cremosinho
no seu bebezinho e compartilha essa
música para espalhar sinceridade que
doar um beijo e até o próximo vídeo